especially when they're trotting
what a marathon is to us a trot is to a
wolf they have no problems covering 70
or 80 kilometers a day
for a hundred years the wolf was thought
to be extinct in germany
but with the eradication of the borders
between the old west and east germany's
the european gray wolf has migrated
westward
a europe-wide wolf hunting ban has led
to a recovery
around the turn of the millennium german
hunters like frankfuss
started reporting sightings of lupus
kanos
in 2009 foss and his wife christina
opened the wolf center in northern
germany
the animal park attracts more than 35
000 visitors a year
the idea is to teach people to accept
wolves
most people still have a stereotypical
view of the creatures
people ask do wolves really howl at the
full moon
and we tell them yes but they howled
during all the moon spaces
still you're very unlikely to encounter
a wolf wild in the forest
in my veins
in most cases the wolf will notice us
human beings
there are around 250 wolves living in 25
wolf packs in german forests a pack
consists of a mother a father and their
offspring
young wolves set out and establish their
own packs when they're one to two years
old
neither streets nor cities nor lakes can
prevent wolf migration
so far most wolves in germany can be
found in the east
although they've begun spreading to the
northwest
wolves are the forefathers of our
domesticated dogs today
fast loves the animals
this is this is serious
he's the one who most often seeks out
contact
christie because we raised him by hand
he's socialized
to be around people that's the way
animals basically think
we belong to people
in the wild wolves feed on wild boar and
deer
for them to find enough prey they need
around 300 square kilometers of
territory
an area roughly the size of a city like
frankfurt on mine
humans used to go after the predators
with traps and poison
they only survived and sparsely
populated parts of europe
like the border between poland and
belarus
today shepherds use electric fences and
dogs to keep wolves away from their
flocks
to effective methods
you need two or three dogs and if a
flock of sheep contains 800
900 or a thousand animals you'll need
three four even five
dogs to guard them
wolves are clever enough to distract a
lone dog so that the other wolves can
get at the sheep
shepherds say that they should receive
financial compensation if
wolves killed their livestock they say
the state leaves them to their own
devices and
imposes unnecessary bureaucracy
wolf stocks are increasing but they are
still an endangered species
there needs to be a thousand adult
wolves so that they can maintain their
health from a genetic standpoint
and we're still a long way from that and
then
you